peu soucieux
bonjour je vous apporte mon téléphone on
préfère ma pour le réparer une marche
bleue et où la portée évidemment
puisqu'il marchait plus enfin écoutez
monsieur n'apporte pas son téléphone à
réparer qu'est ce qu'on fait en jette
mais non mais non mais vous nous
téléphoner et puis on vous envoie
quelqu'un pour vous téléphonez puisqu'il
marche plus bas prix mais oui mais vous
téléphonez d'ailleurs d'où un café
lequel n'importe quel téléphone d'eau
qui bat le leur mais c'est pas le pied
cassé c'est le mien bat bon on est
d'accord mais je ne sais pas vous
téléphonez de chez un voisin mais besoin
non pas le téléphone vos amis n'ont pas
de téléphone
qu'est-ce qui vous prouve que j'ai des
amis ont rien sans lui non pourriez me
dire que parmi les gens qui ont un
téléphone certains pourraient devenir
mes amis c'est vrai que le mais encore
faudrait-il qu'ils n'habitent pas trop
loin de chez moi
pourquoi parce qu'il aurait fallu que je
leur téléphone ah oui c'est exact mais
alors seulement que mon téléphone était
cassée je ne pouvais pas leur téléphoner
pour leur dire que mon téléphone ne
marchait pas c'est clair donc les traits
oui trés trés alors téléphone
perspicaces mais vous habitez vous dans
les deux sèvres pardon dans les deux
sèvres
oui dans les deux sèvres à niort dans
les deux sèvres ou de l'acoustique
numéro zéro au numéro 08 avance at elle
dit ce médecin est tombé ah oui alors
aussi vous habitez niort pourquoi n'êtes
vous parlez au central téléphonique de
niort parce que je n'étais pas à new
york quand je me suis aperçu que mon
téléphone ne marchait plus où étiez vous
à paris dans le xvème dans mon
pied-à-terre alors ce téléphone est le
téléphone de votre pied-à-terre non je
parle de l'événement pied-à-terre
alors ce téléphone bien nous donne your
dans les deux sèvres mai
vous n'avez pas comment l'avez vous
apporter alors sous le bras enfin vous
n'allez pas me dire que vous êtes venue
de niort avec votre téléphone sous le
bras mais si mais si vous avez donc
débrancher les fils et les filles de
téléphone enfin je veux bien qu'ils ne
soient pas dérangés vision d'après mon
téléphone
non non non non mais je veux dire vous
avez débranché à niort pour la brancher
à paris mais à quoi sa mort at il servi
de débrancher les fils de téléphone à
niort pour les branchés à paris tandis
qu'à paris que pour le téléphone mais
rien de temps mais ce fils à ce fils de
will veux rentrer chez moi dans mon
salon et où est-il votre salon à niort
dans les deux sèvres oui je sais vous
savez alors si vous avez vous ne me pose
pas la question
enfin écoutez vous n'allez pas me faire
croire que je ne sais pas où vous avez
400 ou 500 km de files non non non non
j'en ai plus de 5000 quoi oui oui plus
de ça m'évoque arrivé du mans je ne sais
pas que niort paris figurent huit ans je
fais ni à madrid ni à rome ignore
bruxelles tout dépend de ce que j'ai à
faire et toujours a toujours dit je
partais sur mon téléphone alors
j'arrivais dans les endroits le
téléphone ne marchait pas j'avais la fin
et vous vous êtes venus comment de niort
par le train et mais comment
faisiez-vous alors à pour le vendre pour
le fit lors je monte dans le wagon de
queue du train mais l'enjeu allait se
dérouler mon fils delon a beau tirer à
oui mais bien dit que votre pied-à-terre
se trouvait dans le xvème c'est exact
alors pourquoi n'êtes vous pas aller au
central téléphonique du 15e plutôt que
venir ici à celui du xviiie d'après ce
que j'avais des courses à faire dans le
quartier de sa mort
oui bien sûr et vous êtes venu à pied
non par le métro avec votre téléphone
ah oui vous êtes monté dans le wagon
d'enseignants non non non je suis venu
par le tunnel donc ça fait un bout de
chemin
on se dirige alors qu'est-ce qui l'a
téléphone alors écoutez là tout à fait
entre nous si je le savais je serai en
ce moment en blouse grise et vous vous
habitiez niort dans les deux sèvres
bah oui oui mais rien ne nous prouve que
jean un téléphone c'est exact bref ne
marche pas vous avez trouvé les mots
qu'il fallait
bah écoutez je vais donner un coup de
fil personnel je vous en prie faites
comme chez vous vous pourrez juger bon
prix c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux oui
j'avais la province du kivu lui reste
assis - yves assez moscou avait alors
passé - yvan il va c'est toi là c'est
moi ça y est
magnette y est d'à haichao un baril à
reprocher à ce téléphone monsieur j'ai
eu moscou j'avais même pas demandé je ne
vous ai jamais dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
voir moscou et annoncé par ça c'est au
début quand on attend diallo il ya
quelque chose qui ne tourne pas rond
ah oui je jouis
vous n'avez pas tout de suite votre
correspondance ici tu te fais pas
normalement pas non normalement nature à
l'eau vous trouvez ça normal
[Musique]